what about consciousness about my
thinking surely you don't believe that
that's just a bunch of atoms obeying the
core theory of physics so yes I do we
can't prove it right this is something
we believe is true but as a conjecture
that we think is reasonable all I can do
is give you some clues some signposts
along the way okay so this is a C
elegans is a nematode a little tiny
round worm and you and I have 85 or 86
billion neurons in our brain we're
complicated and the task of mapping out
all those neurons is an ongoing one C
elegans has 302 neurons we've mapped
them all out we know how they're talking
to each other we don't know what they do
we don't know neuron by neuron what
their function is but a paper came out
just very recently that said that we
think we have a good idea what one of
these neurons is doing its job when
something pokes the nematode this neuron
says is that did I run into something
that I've run to Iraq or am I just
poking myself its distinguishing between
endogenous and exogenous impulses which
is to say it's telling the difference
between itself in the outside world if
you want this is the first little
glimmer of self-awareness in the
evolution of neural systems it's not
like we have it's not writing novels but
it's telling you know it the difference
being itself in the world and once that
starts just like life you can imagine
how it takes off that's an
extraordinarily useful thing to be able
to do to tell the difference between
yourself and the outside world to hold a
little representation of yourself in
your mind such as it is
here's another step along the way again
maybe this is much more speculative than
physics stuff but this is t2 leak this
is one of the first aquatic animals to
climb up onto land right and there's a
neuroscientist Malcolm McIver who
proposed the following idea if you're a
fish swimming through the water you only
see a few meters ahead of you right the
attenuation length of light in water is
just a few meters and you're swimming at
a few meters per second so if you see
something you only have seconds to
respond to it you don't have a lot of
time for thinking about it okay you got
to decide immediately is good bad what
should I do but when you climb up on the
land
now you can see for miles now there's a
whole new strategy that opens up I can
see something I can think about
different possible alternative responses
to seeing it it is evolutionarily
favored in other words to develop a
Faculty of imagination once you climb up
onto land and indeed this is a theory
that makes predictions because I ever
made predictions for the evolution of
the eyeballs that like the eyeballs
would move up before the fish completely
climbed up on the land and indeed this
is seen in the fossil record don't know
if it's true don't know if it's the
right way of thinking about things
but again consciousness thinking is
something extraordinarily complicated
right now we're just at the point where
we can see how maybe through a series of
remarkable things it came to be
you